ouais ça peut m'arriver j'ai pas fermé à
ça alors peut-être plus du rythm and
blues américain ou du a c'est vrai que
voilà il ya dix ans j'ai l'eau par
exemple qui a sorti un album je l'aï
acheté tout de suite donc ouais je peux
écouter quand même dire à une vidéo
en ce moment j'écoute un peu l'envers on
écoute la même chose c'est très rare
d'ailleurs kendrick lamar le dernier
album entre autres puis après si c'est
après ces bastons d'accord
heureusement d'ailleurs quoi que je
garderai mon nom mais je pense que par
exemple les derniers albums de lino
entre autres il n'y a pas que lui enfin
bref j'ai 100 mire pour l'instant
programmée bien sûr et heureusement
d'ailleurs
moi j'en
duo avec natty tout coup avec j'ai fait
deux dernières tournées qui s'appelle
carré bien dedans dit on va commencer
par faire du live et puis comme comme on
fait de la musique pour aller la jouer
et pas juste pour la vendre donc de fait
on va commencer par faire du live et
faire un peu comme on a envie de
procéder nous et pas forcément comme le
frêne major et ainsi de suite
en faisant le truck radio voilà on va on
va on va revenir aux fondements qui sont
un artiste on veut le voir en live voir
ce que ça dit et puis de là on verra qui
est le premier de la classe
sans donner cette dynamique là commence
à être bâtie moi je j'ai envie de voir
les gens jouer j'ai aujourd'hui je suis
plus enclin à acheter de la musique
quand je me déplace pour aller voir un
concert
voilà je trouve que s'adresse ça devrait
fonctionner comme ça quoi parce qu'à un
moment donné il ya des gens qui ont
oublié de donner une dimension à alive
quand les gens ont acheté ton disque je
trouve pas anormal que il ya des
artistes qui m'ont sur une scène et qui
refont leur disque qui donne aucune
dimension à cet instant quoi et pour moi
c'est primordial